I'm mark Holmes and I'm a fashion
stylist I had been doing music for a
long time since I was a kid that was my
dream always I always wanted to be a
rock star and then I had met a stylist
by chance turned out I had a little bit
of a knack for it both fashion and music
filled with risk-takers so it's a very
natural cohesive thing I think
respecting two fields looking at each
other so this is sort of a history
playbook of a bunch of different musical
fashion elements put it all together in
one look you sort of have your 80s done
all the way to the top kind of look your
classic iconic 50s biker jacket then
you've got your mods silhouette with the
Chelsea boots and the skinny jean
silhouette this feels very cool to me
because it's taking all the things that
I like it's important for everybody to
take little pieces from whatever worlds
they're immersed in and putting those
pieces together and creating an
undeniably cool look just like the
McCallum double cast combining both from
the two sides of the world to create a
beautiful whiskey